so how are things going
it's tough mike wood is a third
generation farmer in california's san
joaquin valley he grows 200 hectares of
almond trees but recently he's been
thinking of selling the ranch yeah the
consideration of sale has been
right in the front of the gray matter
for quite some time actually this valley
is a cornucopia of agricultural plenty
rich soil and a benign climate produced
a vast bounty of meat milk vegetables
fruits and nuts
but global warming is changing the
valley 2021 was the second driest year
on record while some years are wetter
than others repeated drought strains the
capacity of an elaborate system of
canals and reservoirs that bring water
from far away
it's getting hotter too the valley hit a
record 45 degrees celsius in september
land where fruits or vegetables might be
grown would be left idle
it's not unusual to see sites like this
entire orchards ripped up and ground
into mulch
these effects aren't unique to
california china russia nigeria
brazil
all over the world have their own
localized
impacts
but the one thing in common is the
global warming is causing those impacts
and humans are causing global warming
scientists say some of the world's most
important breadbasket regions are also
the most at risk of failure due to
climate shocks persistent drought and
extreme temperatures here in california
and other farming regions around the
world raise an important question about
the future of our species how can an
ever warming planet feed a human
population that is expected to grow from
7.9 billion today to nearly 10 billion
by mid-century
simply expanding farmland won't do the
more forests are cut down the worse
global warming gets
scientists say we must adapt or starve
our ability to be able to feed the
planet is going to require some
wholesale changes both in how we produce
food and how we share food across the
planet
it's going to require that we probably
change our diet and move more towards a
plant-based diet
this is the emitter mike wood is
optimistic that technology will provide
a solution when i talk about the
technology i'm talking about the ability
to
produce
50 to 100 more than we did on the same
acre
40 years ago hope for the future in a
time of climate uncertainty
rob reynolds al jazeera in the san
joaquin valley california